this hasn't happened in almost 40 years
Scotland's teachers taking to the
streets striking overpay
Kirsty teaches geography her profession
far from immune to Rising household
bills I've got two children and one's 12
and one's 15 and I shouldn't have to be
thinking about reducing the sort of
things I normally get them for Christmas
I shouldn't have to be weighing up
um you know whether to put the heating
on in November
hi Mom
is there any chance you could have
Tallulah for an hour obviously just
because of these um School strikes this
is the collateral Suzanne among the
thousands of parents scrambling to sort
Solutions faced with losing a wage I do
have something something for the people
involved but the impact that it has on
me and other people is that we're in the
house we're trying to find something for
them to do we're heating my house or
cooking for them some kids that's the
only helped me all the gate is in school
so that's a big thing for me
teachers have been offered between five
and six point eight percent of a pay
rise but they want more you're looking
for ten percent here that's pure greed
isn't it absolutely not 10 represents in
our real terms picket it's CPI inflation
is sitting at 11.1 percent RPI which is
a more accurate measure for actual cost
of living pressures is sitting at 14 so
10 is actually a pay cut more National
strikes are planned in the coming days
and weeks and the question is will the
Scottish government feel the heat from
parents who are losing wages as a result
of all of this will ministers be
pressurized into tabling a new deal they
say it's not possible they don't have
the cash but how sustainable is that
position the longer this row rumbles on
the wave of industrial action involving
teachers higher education trains and
postal staff continues to sweep the
country
[Applause]
progress on pay stalling Royal Mail
workers out once again campuses hit two
with the biggest university strike in
history and is further real misery Looms
Union Chiefs attempted to break the
deadlock with fresh government talks at
the core of this ongoing economic unrest
is the juggle of wage offers constantly
being outpaced by Rising record
inflation
Conor Gillis Sky News